[Music]
morning guys going to the cow today look
how we just
stations place where they're going to
take our passports we're gonna get a new
stamp on our passport so lots of stance
on our passports for this trip I'm
walking backwards because the lighting
looks really great like this and if I go
like this
see it's really bad so anyway yeah
tomorrow we're going to Shenzhen right
now cities Macau we need some full-time
alright this is really exciting
we're about to drive over the world's
longest bridge over water so I'm calling
to Macau I don't know how long it is
like a measurement but I think they say
it's about 40 minutes long it's just
open recently so not a lot of people
have experienced bridge antenna cool
[Music]
all the bridges
Fikret
all right if you feel better today yeah
I don't know what happened to me last
night I'm throwing up like so I started
blowing up and then I started getting
heartburn I was really trying to hold my
food like whatever food was in there I
was trying to hold it down while I could
eat it to throw up but I think because
we were hiking for such a long time
yesterday I didn't have a single drop of
water so I think I was just really
dehydrated to the point where somehow
that made me feel nauseous
your body just shut it down yeah I was
just shutting it down like I just could
not stay away today I feel better I woke
up this morning and I'm like ooh like
nothing ever happened
we got to go back to the restaurant we
did best night like I'm kind of sad I
miss out because it looked really good
and really cute but I'm okay yeah
Portuguese food today
[Music]
just finished long it was a portion of
the entire bridge where we actually went
underwater it was like and then I'll
talk about that no reason why they did
that is so big ships could get a chance
like you know because it's such a really
long bridge over water in the world
Oh am i quite full yeah you may that's
underwhelming
there's Portuguese
so quick history lesson like how Hong
Kong was colonized by the British and so
Hong Kong has a lot of British
influences Macau was colonized by the
Portuguese so there's a lot of
Portuguese influences here so they have
egg tired so last time we came to Macau
it was really cool - it's such a dope
blend of so many things so it's a blend
of like old European Portuguese style
with like brand-new Las Vegas casinos
like super like Hong Kong like China
it's a really cool experience because
they also have like cobblestone roads
and so it's a really old city here but
yet it's really new - it's really cool
when are we going wait escalators each
tip shows the one that doesn't move in
the middle let it be next to them you
know Macau has the new and the holes
Hong Kong seems like is that they mash
the old and the new
Oh biggest European city I like my count
my guys one of my favorite visits no I'm
still really confused as to which way to
look when I cross wait I know because
since Hong Kong has British influence
they drive on the other side of the road
so every time when crossing streets I'm
always end up looking the wrong way
first and luckily I haven't had any
accidents yet since I'm still standing
here walking talking to you guys all
right hold on action what are you what
do you say mommy offended poco de
español mean hombre se suck me anything
over to habla en porque estamos hablando
can be honest habla espanol
Diana linson un poco and SPM focus hey
Monica most podcast I don't think they
can understand it's okay daddy
[Music]
yeah I called umbrella
[Music]
absolutely yeah
[Music]
[Music]
daddy is dead
[Applause]
[Music]
it's going to Portugal I'm thinking
about that said another stick together
okay
let's join it to it
we're walking down a street here in
Portugal Macau and came across some
Chinese food jerk and we're gonna try
some real quick Isaac's first time
eating beef jerky
[Music]
a professional traveler now you're
picking up the stuff random samples off
the artistry
[Music]
so now we're taking out the casino side
of Macau and we're in this really
gigantic casino called
Grand Lisboa and it's like the one that
looks like this
[Music]
circu we just got into the elevator we
can't really go anywhere I mean I need a
room key look at this looks like me
okay so we spent the last 30 minutes
walking around that's if you or some
ballers walking around casino floor
that's all he was trying to pretend I
was acting like I was unimpressed I like
gold-plated things
either they were oh yeah they did this
so you failed at being rich I was just
trying to go for the Bill Gates tees and
I'm go get Bill Gates is really rich and
he doesn't like the part I wish we gonna
showed you guys the be inside they don't
look like those real
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it was a mission to get our photons well
worth the wait we waited about late 30
30 or 40 minutes with this smell like an
hour like an hour it felt like forever
be waiting in this line right here
before is all the other extreme
the population is closed and everyone is
booing you got it just in time all right
so this street is known for selling beef
jerky pork jerky chicken jerky all sorts
of jerky cat is feeling really jerky to
drink the streets we're gonna get some
jerky samplers for a jerky kid magically
[Music]
more samples to try how do you sleep
like that
[Music]
this is beautiful guys I love the colors
[Music]
Chinese candy
we liked it so much we had to buy it so
this doesn't mean do we have like four
bags in here and then I think like these
a lot
- those are bombs these are delicious
[Music]
all right we are now eating dinner so
we're told there's eggs simply steamed
egg simply it's crazy because it has
like tiny little hairs boys
we don't use the Diggy party who's
nothing I can use a jiggy
we're going home back to Hong Kong fine
Macau careful
[Music]
anyway we got superclass superclass
we're leaving the cow Oh is your mic our
trip always awesome
are you learning your Chinese hey do you
like the Chinese culture and being a
Hong Kong Macau so far it's really
different yeah always feeling for the
past five years we've been kind of
training you for this trip when we went
to Tokyo if we came here instead at that
time do you think you've been able to
have fun here maybe trained you well
[Music]
good morning it is another morning in
Hong Kong I'm back from suburban OA a
cow full moon and woke up super early
today because we're going to Shenzhen so
we're gonna get some breakfast real
quick before heading over to Shenzhen
we're gonna go get some porridge
aka congee aka my mom's favorite and
then everyone else is still sleeping is
super early we're gonna bring back some
breakfast for everyone else this is my
nice the8 it's like a good time I need a
peanut sauce I saw has two sweet stars
combination of all three
[Music]
[Music]
through customs and it was the most
intense like I've never gone through
immigration for that long you know each
person was like a minimally it felt like
10 minutes they were literally reading
our passports like up and down looking
at our ear loathe the know it's my
eyebrows like I've never been staring at
for so long by an official like that
before so I felt criminal but they
really might give us cancer China it
smells bad smell good yeah I'm excited
that I'm excited to explore my own
culture because I've never done this
before and this is our first time doing
this together yeah this is actually this
is the first place that all three of us
together and it's the first time that
all three of us have been here that's
true I do breathing carries pocket
because I smell so bad
I can't breathe in someone's pocket
though look in the Chinese propaganda
right their body would have liked the
Communist like stuff like this is a
the traffic officers just on a song you
guys want to order lunch oh sure
follow me do my job please
[Music]
I feel like I'm home
why because I'm haha so this is over oh
yeah I still don't know what right yeah
this is hot girl village right I don't
know you don't you feel like you're home
so this is a little village that was
built by Hakka people I think but being
with you I think we're the wrong place
because touching is much more closer I
found on you on Google so we're supposed
to have come visited a haka village
which is the type of Chinese people here
in China and my dad had the lineage to
that bloodline I guess oh it does say
haha okay okay so we are in the right
place and I feel like home
what are you doing
pretending I'm old of the house and they
must certain they bring me a cup of tea
I want to be the owner of the house yeah
oh no that that is
[Music]
this is sick this is like some Mulan
stuff right here smoked a lot no this is
how you pray in Chinese culture your
pray to your ancestors and stuff always
kind of like that what's that thing
called in the Spanish culture in cocoa
the a friend yeah this is like the
Chinese ofrenda workout let's go get
some lunch
[Music]
all right so now we are at this is a
Morocco the reason my hands like Morocco
because this is where we're eating our
lunch and in Morocco we had a lunch
where we stopped at someone's house and
they surface a traditional Moroccan meal
here we're going to have a traditional
economy also treated like a hawk
[Music]
so one of my favorite Chinese dishes is
a dish off Isaac Ike which is very sunny
to Hainan chicken and we're told that it
comes from this area originating
[Music]
alright we just finished eating this
meal there's a healthy just say this was
my favorite meal so far we have ever so
good oh it was your favorite - yes
cooking is ok ok I've been drinking from
this seat some deliciosa Budweiser
some whole sick but oh yeah ok oh YUM
why are you have enough yummy drink oh I
didn't know that I just learned
something new in this very moment
Oh YUM holy just a man person but they
turn into terms that I understand system
a young boy who you have that signature
gone boy
so we're in Shenzhen right yep I took a
nap over here starbuck time place it's
not like yeah Peninsula
it's a peninsula right here but just
happen to have they have this old city
or old town whatever and yeah become a
tourist trap
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
you mind the texture before the texture
I that do a lot more flavor to this ever
behind me all right Delphi is tofu help
with a ginger syrup probably one the
healthiest desserts you'll ever find in
the world right cuz tofu is healthy and
so is ginger
[Music]
[Music]
what does the same thing though know
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we're getting pictures from fishes I
forgot what it was we got some sort of
negative experience of it I'm just
thinking like it just happen once don't
drinks it
oh geez oh man it's so hard to get used
to and when your favorite things are fun
and always seen that before and I'm like
gosh I want to try it like they were
crackers though oh yeah your dad's like
what are you guys on crackers
[Music]
building
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cool so we're about to take the metro
Shenzhen Metro on the ticket is cold
yeah getting kind of chilly here
[Music]
that's a really popular jacket tell me
their delivery guy
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
for you
little fishy though
[Applause]
alright hey we're eating dinner again
lots of food on this trip we are eating
snake boy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good
part of their snake yeah all right here
we go snake it never has you tried to
make me go Cheers
I didn't get any me but
Isaak actually saw when they talked off
the head
I mean go to your food you see a little
purple alike you know he's eating it
it's not that great all right stir-fried
dish came out with this nation here
a lot of just using bloopers are good
[Music]
all right so my brother is about the
drink some rice wine with the snakes
wrong gallbladder in it what do you guys
say
Isaac was actually curious about the
fish eyeballs we all see is the best
part
[Music]
whoa that's an eyeball all right over a
bit ready three two one slurp it out
[Music]
[ __ ] it what do you think you don't like
it really that's the first time I saw
and spit something out this little trip
good job baby yeah he's trying to nice
yeah you don't like it all you tried it
[Music]